Predict you better.
It's like you're all wearing the same decoder ring.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Well that is what a lot of it is.
A lot of it is whether or not you believe in God or not.
It's the saying that God's real and the worshiping God and the talking about God
is just letting everybody know that they can predict you.
They know where you kind of like if you're a gentleman,
if you're a gentleman,
you wearing a tie with a nice suit on and pair of pants,
I can fairly likely predict that you're going to be reasonably behaved.
Yeah.
You're a gentleman,
you know,
if you're a Christian,
if you're a person who calls himself a Christian and you know,
well we go to the buy would go to church every Sunday and uh,
I like to read the Bible and I am a Christian and people automatically go,
oh,
okay.
I kind of know where you're coming from.
I can,
I can see where you are.
And now I like that you can predict to me cause you will like me better so we
don't have to talk.
Yes,
no.
All right,
we'll reinforce those,
those patterns in your head.
And I'll say some things that,
uh,
I've repeated things that I've heard other people say about God and Jesus and
yeah.
And it's a nice way to kill time.
It's not a bad way,
you know,
believing in God and going to church and state,
it's a great way you kill time until death nullifies all meaning.
Well I think the community thing of it is a good thing.
There's,
there's some,
there's some really powerful like bonding experiences that people have when they
agreed to be humbled together.
Yeah.
You're describing curling,
curling,
curling.
Great.
That's a sport.
Look,
there's two words in Canada are very popular.
Countering,
curling.
Yup.
That's right.
And there's no way he's curling is one of the top TV shows cannot rise to the
tops of curling without humbling yourself.
Cause you humble yourself the minute you say I'm not to go curly.
When you pick up that brush and a big smile on your face side to sweet bites.
Yeah,
I'm tried.
Curling man.
It's not easy.
No,
it's hard.
Which still doesn't make it a sport.
I made fun of it in Newfoundland and they fucking got so mad at me.
He'll read a theater where I was at like how these pictures of curlers on the
wall and I just could not stop shitting on them yet.
We're like,
hey,
there were legitimately upset.
I'm like,
it is a endeavor,
you know,
and I know it.
You're sliding a rock on the ice.
Yeah.
It used to be a reason to drink.
That's what curling was where everybody,
we had to get steal it.
And you don't fall very far on the ice because we're already squatting.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
And the other people are leaning against brooms.
That's right.
You got a broom to lean against.
It's great you're drinking.
It's also like when you fall on ice,
it's almost always funny always.
Yeah.
No one's,
no one kind of catches himself.
No,
you don't like gently fall it.
You could try to get up as good to know this.
You don't fall elegantly on night hiking and slip a little and catch yourself
and that.
But even like when you're watching the NHL and you'll see players that will just
fall down.
Yeah.
Like just for no reason.
That's hilarious.
These are the best skaters in the world,
and they're just going to fall down on his ass.
He's a professional employee.
Yeah.
And like if I ran ahead and chill with at Volkswagen,
I couldn't knock him over.
Yeah.
Right.
But he just fell.
How long has curling been around a hundred years old.
It's a Scottish court.
It's a Scottish sport where they used to use actual rocks they'd find in fields
and play it on frozen lakes.
The lakes,
because that's the only kind they have in Scotland.
Yeah.
Mm.
Are frozen ones and the lochness monster can around.
There's a lot of,
he's a wonderful curler.
David,
are you Scottish?
I believe I'm from,
yeah,
I've got,
I got the holes.
Shell part Scottish.
I mean,
there's a lot of Scottish people in Canada,
so you can see my curling would be popular,
you know,
very,
very Scottish country Canada.
It's strange.
That's why there's so many gourds.
And,
and Craig's that Gordon Johnson.
Gordon 40.
Yeah,
that's right.
That was a Scottish word,
right?
Yep.
Gordon Gordon.
Yeah,
and of course,
because of Gordie Howe,
everyone named their kids.
Gord.
I went to school with a guy named Greg [inaudible].
I mean,
that was his first name.